the libs are trying to get the
conservative supreme court justices
killed
that's the only explanation i can come
up with as to why a left-wing group just
released the home addresses of amy
barrett john roberts sam alito brett
kavanaugh clarence thomas and neil
gorsuch
the group which calls itself ruth sentes
said quote our 6-3 extremist supreme
court routinely issues rulings that hurt
women racial minorities lgbtq plus
and immigrant rights
we must rise up to force accountability
using a diversity of tactics
rise up
force accountability
diversity of tactics
you'll notice peaceful protesting is
only one tactic not hard to figure out
what they mean by diversity of tactics
but this is just one radical group right
just some fringe leftist terrorists that
have nothing to do with actual democrats
in power right
no actually it turns out that the
democrats in power at the highest levels
of power
are refusing to condemn the threats and
intimidation
these activists posted a map with the
home addresses of the supreme court
justices is that the kind of thing this
president wants to help your side make
their point look i think the president's
view is that there's a lot of passion a
lot of fear a lot of
sadness from many many people across
this country about what they saw in that
leaked document
we obviously want people's privacy to be
respected we want people to protest
peacefully if they want to to protest
that is certainly what the president's
view would be
listen sometimes people get passionate
and they send violent mobs to scare or
even attack the families of judges okay
that it's passion right
even by
the libs standards it is hard
for me to believe what i am hearing from
jen saki but then jen saki goes even
further she makes it clear she was not
stuttering
so he doesn't care if they're protesting
outside the supreme court or outside
someone's private residence i don't have
an official us government position on
where people protest i want it we want
it of course to be peaceful and
certainly the president would want
people's privacy to be respected but i
think we shouldn't lose the point here
the reason people are protesting is
because women across the country are
worried about their fundamental rights
that have been law for 50 years their
rights to make choices about their own
bodies and their own health care are at
risk that's why people are protesting
they're unhappy they're scared
that's the official white house position
the official white house position on
threats against the lives and families
of the supreme court justices at their
own homes is
f around and find out that's what she's
saying
the crooks who cry crocodile tears over
the horn hat guy dancing around the
capitol rotunda on january 6 the
greatest threat to our north these
people are now shrugging their shoulders
when their own fellow partisans send
angry mobs to intimidate judges families
they want to scare them
they want to scare all of us they want
us all to give up and back down and hand
over the country
the overruling of roe vs wade
is the perfect moment for reflection
it's a time when the libs and even many
conservatives thought that we would be
finished and now they're starting to
realize that we're only just getting
started this guy simon quinn this blue
check mark on
twitter liberal blue check
suggests that the libs should go and
assassinate sam alito and clarence
thomas in his thought experiment he's
since deleted the tweet
which was allowed to stay up by the way
the twitter didn't take it down
but he's since deleted the tweet he says
okay you know look i get it i'm catching
a lot of heat for this but but that was
his suggestion and i actually think
it's a good thought experiment because
it exposes the extremism of the libs but
it shows you the whole issue of abortion
the the thought experiment that this
blue check poses is
should we commit an action that is
intrinsically immoral to achieve an end
that we think is good
even though it's not really good but we
think it's good that's a perfect analog
for abortion
abortion poses this question to people
should we commit an action that we know
is immoral namely killing a baby to
achieve an end that we think is good
namely allowing women to go
work at the widget factory more easily
and not have to deal with children and
go i don't know sleep around in new york
city or something
an end that is not actually good but we
are told it is good because feminists
say it's very liberating for women to be
able to kill their children and not have
any attachments to family and to be
totally autonomous individuals that just
go on lots of tinder dates every night
and have fleeting casual sexual
relationships until they're too old and
the men aren't interested in them
anymore and then they just continue to
work for
whatever man in a position of middle
management is that they have been
convinced is a flourishing life
not to put too fine a point on it but
that is
that is the agenda here that's the
really bleak outlook and yet
the the women are told no having a
family that's that's oppressive that's
terrible that's going to really harm you
and and make you weak but
going to work for some other man in the
city some other man who doesn't care
about you and considers you expendable
and going and sleeping not with a
husband who loves you but with men who
just treat you for their own pleasure
and then cast you aside that is somehow
empowering
completely backwards
so it's the the good that we are told is
going to be achieved in the end by
killing the supreme court justice or
killing the baby the good is not really
a good it's that's totally dubious but
the question then
even if even if there would were a good
outcome that might come from it
it still doesn't justify it doesn't
justify committing the immoral action of
killing the judges doesn't justify
killing the baby i was asked at yale a
few weeks ago with senator cruz
some guy came up to to play a prank and
get some jokes from his friends and he
said would you
perform a certain sex act on a man if it
would solve world hunger and this was
supposed to be a big gotcha question
because if you answer yes then hahaha
you say you'll perform a sex act on a
man and if you answer no you're
heartless you wouldn't solve world
hunger but it's actually not a it's only
a confusing question if you view ethics
through the lens of of consequentialism
if you think that the ends justify the
means if you view the world through this
kind of left-wing utilitarian lens that
makes all sorts of calculations and
doesn't think that any actions are
intrinsically morally good or bad but
i'm a conservative baby i'm not one of
these uh so officers economists and
calculators i'm not one of these
rationalist idiots who who thinks the
world operates that way i think that
actions are good and bad in and of
themselves and that's the only thing
that matters
no don't do the weird sex thing with the
dude no don't kill sam alito and
clarence thomas no don't kill the baby
either i'm so glad you like that clip
now
ring that bell smash that like click
that subscribe i don't know whatever the
lingo is make sure you get all the
notifications also head on over to the
michael knowles show apple podcast but
if i stitch your google play we'll see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you